[Music]
alright thank you everyone for joining I
know it's I think the second to last
session of the day after five so
hopefully we'll make it worth your while
so my name is Matt I'm a product manager
at Google cloud platform today we're
going to talk about accelerating
investor insight with commercial data on
gcp so as an investor you likely need to
make decisions with facts and not
feelings you have data you know you need
to get insights from to ultimately make
money and that's why we're all here so
as an investor I need to discover
untapped opportunities understand
behavior what's going on at the regional
and elf of the macro level and also
anticipate future trends now I need to
do all of these things but here are my
challenges commercial data lives in all
sorts of different silos in each one of
them has a proprietary way of disturbing
data to you so either you connect to an
API or you connect to ftp or an SFTP if
you're super fancy or someone will ship
you a hard drive all of these things you
got to plug into your own system and
figure out what you're going to do with
it and spend a lot more effort figuring
out how to unpack that then actually
analyzing the data itself ultimately
which are you are you to investor or you
a data plumber so my personal philosophy
is it shouldn't be this hard talkin
cloud help just to summarize the Google
cloud platform is building a data
marketplace we are hosting commercial
data on Google cloud platform
simplifying distribution so if you have
data in any of these formats we are
targeting specific google cloud products
you distribute them through in terms of
access they're all authenticated through
one single mechanism so if you work with
five different data providers you're not
authenticating five different times
using oauth2 or passwords or special
HTTP headers if you're on cloud platform
use cloud
i M is the same authentication mechanism
you're already using as a cloud user the
idea here is you can log in once and
access all of them all in the same place
and once you have successful in same
place it's ready for use by your
analysts you can use a sequel directly
for data and bigquery you can use a big
query itself if your next forward to
Microsoft Excel you can pull data from
Google sheets for the technical members
in the audience you can also use jdbc no
DBC connectors if you want it for a
Vizier on top bigquery worked out of the
box with data studio tableau click all
those partners up there what say you
have data scientists well now you can
work with data from bigquery or Google
Cloud storage we have a product called
cloud data cloud data lab which is a
Jupiter notebook if you're familiar with
scientific or numerical computing know
python library called pandas we have a
product for that if you want to start
exploring machine learning with
tensorflow reads from bigquery and also
Google Cloud Storage ready to go and if
you have a data engineering team great
you can work with bigquery Google Cloud
storage and also cloud pub/sub cloud
pub/sub is our streaming messaging
product from there you can process it
using data proc if you're familiar with
it you can spark or you can use a cloud
dataflow which unifies both batch and
string processing why are we doing all
of this we want to do this to accelerate
your time to incite so today we have a
few launch partners who will be coming
up talking about how they're delivering
data specifically to dress problems in
the financial services space and I'd
like to invite up al Chang CTO from X
ignite
I type Thank You vet so I'm al Chang CTO
for actually night I want to thank Matt
for inviting us here to speak of this
session well but more importantly I
wanted to thank Matt for reaching out to
us late last year and really being
instrumental in getting us up to speed
on bigquery in such a short amount of
time so in the next few minutes why I'd
like to do is least give you a little
background on who we are actually night
what we do help bigquery plays into our
offerings and end with a short demo
extremely delivers financial market data
over the cloud via REST API we've been
at this for close to 10 years now and we
have about a thousand customers we're
serving about one trillion requests per
year it's not google scale but for us
it's pretty big for a 45 person company
so where we play is basically we're very
strong a new teach in tech space these
are the guys are trying to disrupt the
traditional financial services industry
our customers include the largest Robo
advisors you've probably heard these
names like wealthfront betterment
personal capital these are our customers
these are the guys who are basically
looking at signs for financial advisors
who are hand taking stocks and managing
your money and they're automating and by
the way if you've seen the news these
days ETS are outperforming most active
manage of funds and these guys the Robo
advisors they can charge a fraction of
the cost because they have much lower
cost cases we have some of the most
popular mobile brokers like Robin Hood
who's making a name for themselves by
offering zero dollar commission trades
we have some of these fastest growing
online brokers like motif motif
investment these guys define theme like
sustainability fair trade and they will
help you invest your money in the stocks
and securities that align with those of
those motifs they also let you let let
the community to find their own motifs
which they can also share
interesting social meets finance kind of
a thing in stocktwits this is you know
an example of a one of the biggest
social finance platforms either guys had
to venture to cash tag so the point I'm
trying to hear is that these are
examples of startups that it's great
idea for flash lab and now all I really
need is the market data to power it and
so it should be pretty simple and it is
so if you go to the traditional
providers the thomson reuters the
bloomberg the idc's you first pay a
hefty licensing team then you start to
build your day to beat handlers against
legacy proprietary protocols built in
the 70s you you put your servers out in
co locations in new york and chicago to
be closer to the exchanges on particular
plants you just gotta fill out your own
production database infrastructure to
store the data that you guys had to pull
out and now you build this server
infrastructure that actually serve the
data out to your applications just so
your iphone napkins to show the current
price of Google we think that's kind of
crazy especially because all of this is
not a differentiator please company if
you're if you're a robo visor if you're
doing a social media platform you just
need the data you don't want to spend
that much time and money doing something
that's really a commodity so this is
where I clean I come down we offer what
we refer to as a zero footprint market
data API so basically what that means is
zero production infrastructure to get
financial market data into your app we
have rest api which is basically the
same thing as typing URL into a browser
and that's how easy it is we return data
in XML or JSON which any application
developer can easily bring into a mobile
app or or their websites we offer data
across all asset classes currencies
metals commodities equities options
indices we have real-time data
historical data company fundamentals
basically everything you need for a
financial application in addition to
these request-response api's we also
have other ways to get the data we can
stream the data directly to your
your device we have the ability to let
you define market conditions that notify
you when it occurs maybe your favorite
stock hits a certain threshold you want
email or such we have html5 widgets that
are predefined prepackaged and
customizable which can directly put into
your app once again zero footprint you
don't have to host the widgets we host
them we manage the checking of all the
three conditions on our side cloud
straining same thing we all in
Fletcher's on our side so you don't have
to put anything on your side so which
which brings us to you know why am I
here well we do have one area which we
have quite honestly a very suboptimal
solution for which is basically our
customers who want to do analytics they
have certain algorithms to try to
predict the way the markets going to go
with different data um they want to back
testing based on these troubles to sort
of get a feel for how accurate their
their stuff sort of happen in the past
so today we we all allow the opportunity
to download bulk CSVs which people still
use today we have historical options
data index data equities data we even
have all the trades and quotes for us
exchange for the past 10 years that's a
ton of data which is just terrible I can
share my data yet well i feel i'm at
google it's only chair of licensure
bytes of data is not petabytes of data
but still that's a ton of time which
quite honestly is though so it usually
get a data is sort of what Matt referred
to it's actually getting a hard disk
with the data and shipped to them it's
much faster than trying to bring an
ordinary men so what I like to do now is
show you what we've been working on is
basically taking our historical data and
bring it into bigquery and making it
available directly from the Google cloud
platform can we switch the screen okay
so this first spring here is basically
it's Google bigquery we have tables of
historical data for currencies equities
indexes and metals and the quick very
basic demo but hopeless will get the
point across I like to show you is let's
say that you've heard that goal is a
great hedge against the stock market it
says markets going down the old
vice versa so let's do it let's just
test that out um what I have here on my
laptop is basically our studio very
common tool you can take until you want
to give me example where I'm essentially
just making a script so it makes a
direct sequel call should be queried to
pull the historical time series data for
gold for it's kind of funny originally
my demo was with the essence against the
sp500 but since Tawny's here i just
changed it five minutes ago that you
pull the dow jones industrial average
for the dow jones industrial average and
for a gold-mining stocks a new newport
mining so it's really do a query check
the correlations and plot the data so
you run this thing and out pops a quick
graph that shows you though the red line
i believe is gold green line is dow
jones and the blue line is newport
mining so even visually you can see
there's a very interesting correlation
but you actually get the actual values
as well a correlation of 0 point 65 with
Newport mining and a negative point four
or five with the Dow Jones average so
you get appeal for not just is it
negative positive but even how much now
really simple example right but the
point here is that I never had to
download CSV and ever had to put in my
own database and never had to sort of
maintain it at that solution if I wanted
to I could even go back and say well let
me just check those guilty sp500 take a
different one on it
with my one commander is huge and you
can it's over and over again so so too
does post-mortem going to try it out
it's all up there in the cloud so can we
switch back to the presentation so just
in closing just want to share with you
that today we do have sample data up
there for you to try and give it a final
easy it is and we have obviously a lot
more data that's in our sample but this
is at least an example to give you a
flavor for how easy it is thank you all
right thank you I'll so I don't know if
this is clear earlier every provider we
spoke we have on stage today we've asked
to provide a sample if you're interested
in licensing their commercial data you
work with them directly so next up I'd
like to introduce Jeremy cyclic CEO of
house canary great thank you Matt thank
you everyone so today we're going to
talk a little bit about residential real
estate residential real estate in the
United States is a 30 trillion dollar
market it's the largest asset class in
the United States or the world for that
matter and whether you're a major hedge
fund you're a big investor you're a big
lender or even a you know just a
homeowner we all struggle with two
fundamental questions number one what is
the value of this property and number
two is the price going to go up or is it
going to go down in a house canary
that's what we've been focused on
solving and providing to a number of
sophisticated investors and lenders over
the last couple years using massive data
sets and a lot of machine learning that
I know is being talked about a lot and
we're excited to put a couple parts of
our platform on the Google cloud
platform today so let's talk about kind
of the state of affairs in real estate
today massively fragmented
essence you have 120 million properties
in the United States every property is
its own unique snowflake they're all
different and underlying that the data
is super fragmented you've got three
thousand or thirty two hundred different
County Assessors and public recorders
seven hundred and fifty different
multiple listing services a number of
other sources the problem is is every
one of those data sources are all
different there's no common data
standards so the information that you
get from one never aligns with the next
the definitions of what it means are all
different and in many cases it's all
still paper-based that's what's slowing
down the process of buying homes lending
on them so we've been really focused on
is really bringing this information
together about this massive asset class
bringing in the 21st century and largely
indexing all the details about every
home every mortgage in every
neighborhood and when you do that
there's three things that this really
starts to enable number one we can get
deeply detailed today if you sort of
read the newspaper it'll come out that
case shiller says that Chicago is up by
four percent but what does that mean
about my local area for us we're now
providing that level of detail by every
381 us metropolitan areas 18,000 zip
codes every zip code where there's a
population of 1,000 or more and now
blocks three million blocks how our
price is changing getting down to the
details the second area is really being
predictive past is not prologue for the
future I think we've all sort of
realized that through what's happened in
the markets over time and the idea is to
bring the history but then also use
machine learning and predictive
analytics to really forecast what's
going to happen in the markets using
data that no single human could ever
figure out it's too complicated at this
point and finally just building you know
bringing the amount of data that you you
can bear and building highly accurate
values for 90 million homes that are
updated monthly
till values for 60 million homes given
how large single-family rental is now as
an asset class so to make this real what
we wanted to do and what we did it was a
really easy process for us as we loaded
about a billion data points from house
canary from our platform into bigquery
and then we basically put on top tableau
so it's just fully stock what we're
going to show just pulling some examples
out so given that we're in San Francisco
want to sort of start with an example
around prices what's happened with
prices in San Francisco over the last
year most people would say well the
price is changed by about nine percent
on sort of you know right right in this
area but if you sort of look at it on
the low end you've got Pacific Heights
in red that basically grew by seven
point one percent you've got the mission
a couple miles away at a zip code level
that grew at thirteen point six percent
and if you go out to the east bay and
parts of Oakland it's even grown by a
lot more than that but now the idea is
to not only del that deal at the block
level or at the zip code level but
actually to then dig in block by block
that's where investments are made that's
where money's made and lost and so for
us you know feeling down now at the
block level we dig into these zip codes
and provide this information there's
these nice parent-child relationships
that we've linked everything together so
I can look at multiple levels and now
we're down at the block level looking
into the future and basically I can see
that there's parts of San Francisco that
are likely to decline in our declining
right now at a block-level parts of the
Presidio and you go a few miles away and
prices are going up double digits and
for us that's the dispersion of returns
getting down to the segmentation that's
where the information is really
available in the opportunities for
making better in bed
Schmidt and lending decisions so now
let's actually think about how we might
actually take that one more level down
to properties for house canary what
we've done and what we've put up in the
big query and gcp is basically for every
single property we have a unique
identifier link to the address linked to
the latitude and longitude so now you
can start actually looking at every
property not only against house canary
data but linking it to your own
databases linking it out to other data
sets that will talk about where latitude
longitude enjoins are really important
and you can start identifying
opportunities in this case we just
pulled up to properties sold at about
the same time look very similar what's
going to happen you know over the next
year one's likely to have price decline
so that the other is likely to have
price increases but this is it really
all about doing this with two properties
this is about lots of properties and so
you know whether you're a major lender a
major investor a retailer this is where
the use case really comes in for how to
use this kind of information so maybe
I'm a major lender and I'm thinking
about I hold loans in the San Francisco
area for those loans that I have which
ones are going to see increases which
ones are going to see declines where's
their opportunity where is their risk
how do i change my lending practices how
do I manage risk ahead of time I might
also be an investor that's not comparing
to my current portfolio but I might be
looking for new investment opportunities
and you can start to think about how I
start to look at investment
opportunities that may be coming up
through different bankruptcies through
MLS linking it to our evaluations our
rental analytics if I'm if I'm looking
to rent and thinking about where prices
are starting to increase or decrease
many many opportunities to
to basically search find opportunities
so on gcp we've basically loaded as I
mentioned about a billion data points to
begin off of our platform there's a lot
more where this came from and you know
based on sort of interest and where
where where the interest in everybody
guides us will continue to add more but
really what we've done and what was
started with was basically adding first
home price indices home price indices
for all us metro areas 18,000 zip codes
that cover about ninety-five percent of
the u.s. population and three million
blocks and for each of those we've
basically provided historical monthly
updates for the last forty years so you
can see about three economic cycles and
forecasts we've also included our
valuations that are third-party reviewed
and ranked as is the most accurate in
the market for 90 million homes and then
finally our rental values on 60 million
homes that are used by some of the big
household names and the big
institutional investors who have gone
out bought a lot of real estate set
rents and all of these are updated
monthly at this time so as map talked
about you know where we see the real
opportunity is kind of some of those
heat maps and digging in starting to
join and analyze it used to take us
months to really do this with whole
teams of analysts and I was helping by a
lot of properties out of the Lehman
crisis and out of the sort of out of the
downturn and now you know it takes a
person a couple minutes to really start
joining analyzing identifying
opportunities identifying risk and for
us that's what's exciting about this is
the ability to just make better
decisions much much faster than ever
before
and so with that here's the URL you can
go try it out and we'd love to get your
your input thank you very much all right
Thank You Jeremy next up I'd like to
invite tony ahsoka from joe jones to
talk about his product thanks matt and
thanks for having us here and talk about
dow jones and they attacked content and
data that we have and and how you know
financial firms and investors are
leveraging news content to help you know
accelerate their their insights so the
data landscape is changing quite a bit I
think everybody knows that we've seen it
quite a bit you know at the conference
as well over the last couple of days
right more and more companies are you
know putting a heavy investment into big
data and they realize that in order to
really stay relevant in the future in
coming years they need to evaluate how
they can really leverage big data you
know in a in a way that that can
actually give them a competitive
advantage and so forth stay relevant in
in their respective you know lines of
business and there's a great opportunity
for us now with the accessibility and
availability of a lot of these new
technologies right a lot of technologies
that we've heard over the past couple of
days at Google a lot of open source
technologies around big data what they
call computing capacity that we now have
available to us through the cloud and so
on right and so now you know
organizations are really looking at
leveraging that technology leveraging
caught the content and data they have in
order to be able to now really drive
innovation right within their
organizations they're trying to move up
the stack from you know just data and
information to automating things like
knowledge and wisdom right if you hear
this all the time in terms of what what
people are trying to do with things like
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and so really companies
right are are trying to move past
information it's the information is no
law
enough to really stay ahead right people
really need actionable intelligence
that's very relevant to their use case
that's accessible that's also
customizable for their particular
business case and this is where we feel
Dow Jones can really help address a lot
of those challenges right and and really
help customers and investors like
yourselves and financial firms like
yourselves take advantage of the premium
use content now Jones has been you know
creating news around you know economics
around finance around businesses and so
forth that's our bread and butter right
we've been doing it for over a hundred
twenty-five years We Are The Wall Street
Journal we are MarketWatch we are barons
where financial news so we have a wealth
of content and not only that we have we
also have a very rich taxonomy so we
have a a robust data strategy team that
actually curates and updates the
taxonomy that we apply on top of our
content which makes now our content even
more valuable in terms of how you might
be able to leverage it within your firm
to deliver insights and around your
particular use cases right we have over
30,000 sources of content so beyond just
the content that we create we actually
ingest all sorts of other publications
premium news across the globe and we
actually then apply this route taxonomy
on top of it in over twenty eight
different languages we have over 19.5
million public and private companies
that are encoded in this taxonomy we
have over 1500 new subjects that are
encoded in this taxonomy over 2400
regions and we have over 1.2 billion
documents and growing in our archive so
it's a wealth of wealth of you know
content that now people are starting to
leverage in terms of whether it's quan
firms whether its wealth managers
whether it's you know financial advisers
in terms of being able to take that
build predictive models now that can
help drive how they do their investments
so you know we're very excited to do a
little you know soft launch of dow jones
DNA DNA stands for data news and
analytics it's a new platform that we
developed completely on google it's
leveraging a lot of Google's you know
Big Data technologies a lot of a lot of
stuff that Matt talked about earlier
we're leveraging data flow and data proc
Google Cloud storage and bigquery to
make the our wealth of content now
available to customers in a much more
accessible way that can really help them
innovate and push the envelope in terms
of how they could leverage content
within their business right we have
three main ways of being able to access
this content we have what's called
snapshots to be able to get large
archives in the past when customers came
to us and said hey we'd like to get a
year's worth of you know your news
archive it would take us weeks to
deliver it and would deliver it via FTP
and csv files and it was it was really
difficult for customers to be able to
really take advantage of that now with
things like you know Google cloud we can
deliver a 30-year archive 100 year
archive in literally an hour 30 minutes
to an hour right so it's really changing
the way customers can take advantage of
our content whether is to do back
testing to build predictive models
whether it's to leverage it to do you
know specific research around very
specific use cases and so on and another
way we're delivering this is through
what we're calling streams we're
actually using google cloud pub/sub to
be able to deliver our news content in
near real-time to customers so imagine
now you going to be able to go in
leverage a 30-year archive of news build
a predictive model and then apply that
predictive model now on a stream and and
now essentially delivering to you
real-time insights that actually is
actionable that you can you can actually
take and start automating within your
organization and then we also have a
rich set of API is that we're building
out on top of the cloud as well to be
able to do much more of the you know
request response type of use cases where
you might want specific data because we
also have a wealth of company data for
example and so forth so you may want to
you know understand what's going on with
a specific company in terms of their
their profile and and you may want to
correlate that right with with news
content and so forth we have searched
api's as well to kind of really dive
deeper into the news content if you're
looking for very specific pieces of
information and we're building a very
you know accessible ecosystem around us
as well to make it easier for customers
to be able to leverage this new platform
you know we're launching a new developer
portal we're building out a customer
solutions engineering team ourselves and
you know we're really building out our
partner ecosystem with part
like Google in terms of making our data
more available to our customers and
these are some of the very cool things
that people are starting to do now with
this new platform and with this new
accessibility to premium news content
internally we had a little Co Devon and
literally net in a matter of days we
were able to build these cool little
Bassets right we were actually
leveraging Google's natural language
processing API on top of this platform
to do things like geo encoding and
sentiment analysis and so forth on top
of the data right we were doing things
leveraging our streams to show real time
you know trending topics trending
companies trending sectors things of
that nature that you could start doing
and then we were also build out a little
demo to show you know where you can type
in a company you can kind of see the
news volume about that company over a
timeline right and all this now is very
easy even for you guys to do internally
within your within your business and
these are some of the other things that
people are for example leveraging our
content for imagine being able to go in
again because we have a very robust
taxonomy to be able to quickly
understand the impact of various trade
sanctions across the globe right so
basically searching through our taxonomy
that talks about compliance and embargo
and sections you don't have to be an
expert in these things you can actually
leverage our taxonomy and build on top
of that imagine being able to understand
the effect of giant you know China's
economic slowdown across the globe right
again you can mine our content for the
you know four key terms keywords across
our taxonomy in terms of looking for
economic slowdown creating a heat map
around that type of the type of stuff
and understanding whoa there's seems to
be some you know really hot areas in
terms of you know economic impact of
potentially you know the Chinese
economic slowdown imagine being able to
track vaccination trends across the
globe with our news content and how is
that impact for example you know
investments in the pharma industry right
oh we see the spread of Zika go across
these other regions do we need to invest
in vaccinations there are pharma
companies investing in vaccinations in
those kind of areas and so forth right
so this is just the
tipa dice right i mean you can imagine a
lot of different ways you could leverage
this news content to really kind of
drive how you guys are doing investment
and that's really the power of you know
of this platform on what premium news
can really do for for your business so
we love people to come in and try it out
we have a sample data set that's out
there in bigquery we always have a much
more robust data set than that from you
know if you actually licensed our entire
content but we have a nice little
snippet here that you can play with it's
actually brexit data or related to
brexit in a way because we have all of
our news that we created the days up to
the brexit and a few days after so you
can kind of start you know digging in
and seeing and analyzing you know how
that the impact of the brexit beta was
across the globe and then we also have a
nice landing page if you guys want to go
and learn more about our DNA platform
learn more about our content learn more
about what other customers are doing you
know we're leveraging this new new new
platform so we're excited to you know
see customers levered premium news in
different ways than you know prior but
then it was you know ability to in prior
times right okay great thank you Tony so
next up we actually have accuweather I
wasn't sure if they would be able to
make it this time but today we have
rosemary joining from accuweather who
will actually be covering her own slides
thank you all right okay so how many of
you when you're meeting a stranger for
the first time you have to try to think
of something to talk to them about well
usually one of the first things you
talked about is either television or the
weather because weather effects so much
of our everyday lives it affects how
many steps we take affects what music we
listen to it affects and of course most
importantly what consumers by which is
what you know investors really care
about but there are some challenges in
order to predict human behavior it
requires a large amount of data in a
large amount of technology and we know
the environment has a strong impact on
consumers but again predicting human
behavior is very difficult I'm a
sociologist by training
we usually say it was easy be rocket
science so every piece of information
you have to help you predict what
consumers are going to do it will help
you improve your model so the
environment has a huge impact on
consumers and most importantly whether
have an effect as well so our solution
we want to make sure that you have
access to highly accurate and reliable
historical weather data so if you have
bad data coming in no matter how good
your modeling is how advanced your
machine learning techniques are if the
data behind it is bad then the output is
going to be bad as well we've had
several of our clients come to a sane we
heard about this other data source the
website looked great and we did a little
bit of digging and we found out it was
some guy working out of his mom's
basement you know playing xbox half the
time so you want to make sure you do
your due diligence when you're looking
for these data sources to ingest so
having you know a good source like
Google with reliable partners is very
important and so having this weather
information allows you to unlock these
aspects of human behavior and to uncover
new insights so even the short and sweet
if you want to try our data set we're
here is the link we have minimum maximum
temperature precipitation and snow falls
so it's a really small subsection of the
vast amount of data that we have just
one year of data but we actually have
highly granular data going all the way
back to nineteen fifty-one we have
hundreds of different metrics including
realfeel where you can see the impact
that temperature has on consumers so we
have a large amount of data so if you're
interested in more information for what
we have in terms of spatial temporal
granularity and additional weather
metrics feel free to come and talk to me
later thank you
okay so thank you act whether they're
just getting started in the program
sample is just a very small snippet of
what they offer will be working with
them to develop a more comprehensive
offering in the near future next off I
also was surprised that we were able to
have the speak from remind here so we'll
have Jonathan from remind covering his
own slides as well all right good
evening guys so mom Jonathan spinetto
with remind and what we focus on is
predictive sale intelligence around SF
our real estate so what we do is we take
a look at all the data like Jeremy
mentioned earlier it is very a lot over
3200 Assessors nationwide multitude of
different variables and we combine it
with transactional property data and we
also to combine it with consumer
intelligence so in bringing in
attributes such as month and year of
birth and other individual household
level demographic attributes to
understand when a house will be going up
for sale so as a Realtor a mortgage
professional or other type of industry
understanding when those homes will be
selling is what we focus on and what we
talked about trying to obtain that 360
degree view is important so my
background is actually full time in real
estate so I've been a licensed agent
since I was 18 years old myself my other
business partner we participated over
6000 residential transactions nationwide
one transaction at a time working with
banks are working with other parties and
really gives you an insight to
understand you know what goes on at that
level right what is in the mindset where
are there certain life events and life
actions that we can break down these
activities into an understanding equity
understanding length of ownership
because usually what you hear is the net
the statistic that the national
association of realtors puts out that a
home sells every seven years well let's
get more granular with that and let's
understand how we can figure out where
that information is going to come into
play so what we do is we look at a
classification of understanding that
sale in a six months 12 months 18 months
and a 24 month plus timeframe so by
bringing in all of this data together
we're able to bring this data now
available on the Google
cloud as a commercial data set and one
of the things that we do have up there
is this snippet from our data it's in
Alaska and Anchorage where we have that
classification of understanding the
sales up there so take a look try it out
reach out to us we're happy to discuss
more about what we have around that
predictive sale and other attributes
across the United States for SF far and
we're happy to be working with Google on
this so thank you guys okay great thank
you Jonathan and so just to wrap this up
we had a great showcase of launch
partners here who really saw where
bigquery could go and pretty much jumped
in with us why are we doing all of this
we are accelerating your time to incite
by doing all of these things pre hosting
the data on gcp simplifying distribution
simplifying access and making it
accessible for not just analyst a data
scientists and data engineers as well
you can learn more at cloud google com /
commercial data sets on there you will
see a listing of all five of our
partners today links to their sample
data sets as well as how to contact them
for licensing tails on their offerings
[Music]
you